qui ne connaît pas les baronets le
public québécois découvrent pour la
première fois rené angélil au début des
années 60
aussi
le comité
c'est toi un des
si le membre du trio les baronets a la
cote auprès d'un jeune public
c'est surtout dans l'ombre d'autres
artistes que l'homme né à montréal est
d'origine syrienne connaît le succès
d'abord avec rené simard le nouvel
imprésario s'est vu confier la carrière
du jeune chanteur par guy cloutier je
crois un agent spectacle d'accord les
gens disaient très sérieux mais je suis
même pas un vrai le monde la connaît et
n'a retenu que rené angélil s'établit
finalement à son compte
il gère la carrière de ginette reno qui
devient la plus grande chanteuse du
québec jusqu à ce qu elle le conduit
j'ai été humilié d'avoir été mis de côté
par peur par gina thé son hammam mêlée
presario remercie n'a pas gardé de
rancoeur c'est grâce à elle si une
famille de charlemagne lui poste
l'enregistrement de la voix d'une
certaine céline dion
il décide de tout miser sur elle moi
j'aime m'occuper d'un artiste qui en
vaut la peine
plutôt que d'en avant 5 c'est ce qu'ils
sont très bons mais qui on cite le
talent et que ça va rester au québec
le temps lui donnent raison
au québec en france aux états unis
partout dans le monde c'est lundi on
vend plus de 200 millions d'albums et
récoltent tous les honneurs comme un
oscar pour la meilleure chanson
originale du film titanic
leur relation professionnelle se
transforme au fil du temps rené et
céline se marie en 1994 et renou leurs
voeux six ans plus tard
après la naissance de leur premier fils
rené-charles le coq s'installe pour un
contrat de cinq ans à las vegas céline
dion livres jusqu'à cinq spectacles par
semaine
et la santé de rené angélil la mise à
rude épreuve à plusieurs reprises crise
cardiaque à 50 ans cancer de la gorge en
1999 puis une rechute presque quinze ans
plus tard c'est important pour nous que
rené se consacre à sa santé et qui
prennent le temps de prendre du temps
justement pour lui pour récupérer
tu
céline dion a nulle même une longue
série de concerts à las vegas et en asie
pour être à son chevet une complicité
inébranlable qui caractérise bien
l'union entre rené angélil et sa
protégée depuis plus de trois décennies
ici pascal harrison junior est au canada
moyenne